[Musique]
les amis le thread dorée dit vous avez
beaucoup plus mais alors du coup après
ça je me suis baladé sur reddit emec
cjrc une 1000 d'or vient dé sled qui
parle de tout et de rien il y en a un
qui m'a fait particulièrement rire qui
s'appelle crappy design en gros c'est
des photos du quotidien d'endroits où
d'objets du quotidien mais qui sont mal
foutu mais vraiment très mal foutu à tel
point qu'on se demande comment c'est
possible que des mecs aient fait ça sans
se rendre compte de la connerie
aujourd'hui nous allons ensemble
regarder les meilleurs de ces images
alors ce que j'aime bien avec les dit
aussi c'est dans les threads des images
changent tous les jours toutes les
semaines luxe et un système de vote par
exemple si tu as vu ce serait déjà une
semaine et que tu retournes dessus
aujourd'hui il y aura des nouveaux trucs
et c'est ça que j'adore bref découvrait
dit un peu après la guerre après que
tout le monde sache que c'est mais bon
mieux vaut tard que jamais comme on dit
dans le milieu quand on est un looser
alors je le dis très souvent ça commence
par ça ok donc là je suis juste confus
sur ce que je dois faire quand je me
retrouve dans cette situation
make panneaux excite panneaux qu'on
utilise en plus si jamais il ya un feu
tu vois hélas là vraiment y'a le feu
t'es pas bien et est au pied du panneau
sortie tu as réussi tu vas t'en sortir
non non non aux gamins cette pop n'est
pas une sortie c'est horrible mixer au
but c'est quoi c'est pas une sortie mec
lui désolé porte comme ça c'est
totalement des sorties ça se trouve
c'est une sortie et le mec a mis ça pour
faire genre que c'est pas une sortie
comme ça si un chien feu les gens
meurent je regarde beaucoup trop de
thriller et de reportages psychopathe ça
a pas du tout ce banques qui cherchent
des téléphones à l'aide de l'énergie
solaire est placée sous un arbre dans
l'ombre d'un immeuble sa croûte grave de
la thune en plus de faire ces de
bord mettez le au moins là où il fait
beau je pensais qu'on avait appris ça
qu'on avait quatre ans une le vraiment
le dos d'une tasse ben voilà c'est
roncquois ça peut vraiment pas aller
dans le carré d'une assiette à moins que
le carré soit plus grand que le rond
mais là ça ne marche pas du tout cela
est un peu ingrat joue là vous parce que
c'est évident que cette assiette est
faite pour servir les espresso dans des
toutes petites astuces est élu il a
demandé un café allongé voir américain
sans fils doit et du coup le serveur
était triste parce qu'il a que ces
assiettes là il sait qu'elles rentrent
pas dans le carré bref ou h prend la
défense de tout et n'importe quoi orange
c'est quoi le problème
bah oui ok j'ai compris quand je
comprends je me met un doigt dans
l'oreille c'est bien ça c'est un symbole
orange normalement à savoir orange
dessus il ya des photos d'orange mais là
comme c'est halloween ils ont mis des
photos de citrouille
alors les gens étaient troublés et pensé
que c'était à la citrouille alors que
lens est alors anges quand on voit un
frigo un légume sur un produit est bon
on imagine que le produit sans le fruit
légume en question si je suis en train
de faire une thèse sur dû s'avancer ben
clément il faut qu'on prenne des
vacances
[Musique]
quelle horreur ah mais ils ont mis un
de poteaux devant sa porte
d'entrée non mais c'est pas possible
s'il est malin il peut devenir hyper
musclé en un an ils se fixent une
condition dès que je sors ou rentrent de
chez moi je fais le drapeau sur ce
poteau pendant 10 secondes
emballé pesé les muscles arrive en fin
d'année comme ça avec le bonus de prime
de salaire aux reborn night is great
arrêter là tous les petites fusées la
toute petite cuisine là les petites
usines mimile un arrêté de sortir des
produits dérivés fait avec le coeur il
faut les faire avec vos mains des fesses
ne sont pas capables de le faire
correctement je vous assure le placement
du capteur dans cette salle de bain à
will est trop loin et du couffo 14
notamment ingénieur je veux faire
beaucoup d'années d'études pour embêter
les utilisateurs de toile est ok ya un
problème de conception
maintenant je vais te dire un truc au
moins c'est clair le capteur est loin il
faut mettre la main devant pour que
l'eau coule des fois gros le capteur est
proche mais il marche pas tu mets ta
main tu es là tu es comme un coup tu
fais ça la soul olaru qui détecte sais
tu ta pote de tu as comme ça c'est
chiant n'en parle pas assez de ces
captures qui marche pas non mais en vrai
camp américain dessine plus tard
pourquoi il a des flèches et un gone meg
les flèches vrai pas dans le carquois
comment je suis supposé lire ça c'est
quoi cette merde c'est quoi qui
s'appellera c'est que ça doit parler
d'huile ou un truc comme ça et du quiz
où ils ont voulu montrer de quoi ils
parlent et mes longues sur le texte est
malin malin faut pas écrire des livres
quand c'est pas faire aux j'adore ce
cube magique je pourrai plus jamais
peut-être c'est la marque juste en fait
ça s'appelle le msp porte donc tu as
voulu faire une blague alors que tout
est clair sur ce packaging c'est pas
bien mais quelle idée et en plus il ya
de l'herbe partout autour quelle idée ça
me rend fou la vraie question quand on
voit ça c'est qui a posé le deuxième but
qui est quelle bonne deuxième
qui a tort dans l'histoire famous asia
donc célèbre restaurant asiatique et ils
ont mis un chef italien nick la logique
et il est content il est content en plus
d'être là de représenter l'asie est ce
qu il a même 1 % d'asie en lui cet homme
non increase the race améliorer votre
fessier comment tu faire des efforts de
typo comme ça c'est de la prod
au lieu de mettre ça comme ça où tout
est compréhensible
ils ont mis ça comme ça on dirait que ça
veut dire giants à ce qui veut dire qu
géant c'est génial
comment l'esprit humain peut-il être
superficie il ya vraiment un semblant de
testicules là c'est pas du tout un motif
sexuelle regardez petit test pour
vérifier si vous avez l'esprit perverti
ou pas the count down
le couac honda en exactement est ce que
vous pouvez me dire j'arrête pas aller
si vous avez lu annales vous avez
l'esprit perverti carrière marquée fine
holmes avec le à deux gauchers plus gros
pneus à de droite moi je vais pas vomito
j'avais vu direct the what comes down et
je n'ai qu'une parole vous le savez les
mecs vous faites une partie trash et une
partie recyclables on voit bien qu'il
n'ya qu'un sac qu'il n'y a pas deux
parties ne fait pas genre si c'est pour
mettre 15 5 en dessous arrêter un peu
creux vouvoie nous franchement les gars
faisait pas penser que je comprends vos
d'inscrits se voulait montrer aux gens
qui rend les dents blanches et tous
qu'il est je comprends très bien mais m
3 de blanc ensemble avec en
dessous marque et white power c'est pas
bon il faut comme faire une vidéo qui
contient des hommes politiques
et si on faisait une porte genre pour
aller sur un trottoir a laissé un
terrain de pétanque aurait cependant
trottoir à vannes était à chier mais
vous êtes habitués mais ce qui est plus
plus troublant sur cette image c'est que
si j'y vais j'ai vraiment envie de
passer par la porte chez papy dans
janvier je revis doué ce truc là et de
les refermer derrière moi pour montrer
je suis dedans c'est psychologique non
ça ne fait pas ça c'est génial on
découvre des choses assure le cerveau
humain ces vidéos là c'est la recherche
ans et travaillait à tiens tiens tiens
asus et republic of gamer
cette poignée n'est pas homologué c'est
pour rattraper les scolioses qu'on chope
à force d'être assis de travers sur nos
chaises gens c'est plus simple à porter
quand la poignée n'est pas centré un
juge l'a fait en théorie pour vous des
fours n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un pc
qui m'a sauvé cette vidéo je vous aime
pas ok les a mis là c'est foot et en
soirée un pote renverse un peu son verre
sur toi que tu tapes dans son verre
optent en appelant l'épaule mais tu as
aussi très envie de faire pipi tu peux
faire l'un ou l'autre ou les deux en
même temps son dernier espoir c'est quoi
c'est tombé sur ça avec tu peux te
sécher l'épaule on en tue pis non avril
à bethesda est horrible c'est la
peinture il ya un mec là là qui est
comme ça qui met ses mains sous le truc
comme ça qui veut pas te déranger par
une tuerie mais il a quand même envie
d'avoir les mains sèches avant de
retourner au repas c'est terrible or les
noms ils vont qu'un qu ils ont mis deux
lettres dans le dernier du coup c'est
l'enfer ça fait partie de ces images
hyper insatisfaisante venant se cotise
on lui donne le dernier tube dance est
trop triste c'est quoi cette affiche est
même franchement c'est un club idéal
mais il est bien fait genre l'endroit
est respectée on a visé l'un d'entre eux
on n'a pas dégradé de franchement c'est
clean
on devrait tous se balade avec un tuyau
comme ça la vie serait bien meilleure ce
plug & sb brille plus que le soleil je
le veux c'est génial mais qd on branche
partout sur toutes tes prises chez toi
et tu fais une soirée tapas besoin
d'acheter de light ou quoi c'est déjà en
bien son nom c'est une idée de merde ok
le gars est sur un jeu mobile est
apparemment saint-just qu'ils avaient
pour les majeurs donc le jeu mais un
petit avertissement et veut qu'un parent
accepte que son enfant il joue les mecs
qui ont eu une idée ils ont mis une
interface s'il te plaît peux tu
confirmer que tu es le parent le
responsable légal en complétant ce
calcul 68 mois 59 genre y'a que les
parents qui peuvent résoudre ça mec
monga même natsu il sait résoudre ça je
te jure pour arrêter la peinture dans
ses toilettes publiques
on dirait qu'un enfant a joué
avec du gâteau au chocolat hockey ici on
a un pommeau de douche apparemment qui
est pas bien aux îlots mais la part de
l'autre côté ce génial je pensais même
bikes devoteam mec bex la main les
ingénieurs de poubelles se sont alliés
avec les ingénieurs des escaliers pour
créer leurs plus belles pièces
bonjour c'est beau ça nique le couloir
du milieu mais c'est bon bravo les gars
mais c'est scandaleux de mégastar bugs
et sur le code-barres kacou les magasins
bien marquer ok pour le lave vaisselle
et le micro ondes et quand tu retires
les tickets le constructeur delà de la
tasse lui a marqué non pas ok pour effet
chrome c'est du foutage de gueule mais
que c'est fou de faire ça c'est bon des
bâtards non halal à ils ont déconné
c'est hyper grave
le t-shirt playstation les couleurs de
ronds carrés x trail ne sont pas
respectés ils ont inversé les couleurs
ils ont mis le triangle bleu et le
maître verizon milleron vers l'ue de
mettre ou géo ça brise le coeur je veux
pas aller plus loin et passer moi ça ça
dégage au filet sur celui-là il est
parfait sembas nos guides et qu'il faut
ralentir parce qu'il ya une aire de jeux
d'enfants bailly met ça y est vous à
mort ça mais les mecs là qu'on conçu ce
panneau mais vos enfants mais déclare
que c'est pas comme ça qu'on joue les
regardais pas faire croyez pas que c'est
normal si vous enfoncent joue comme ça
c'est pas normal je suis désolé de vous
l'apprendre mais hélas pour vous on
dirait que tout le monde joue comme ça
non
les avis c'est la fin de ce petit tour
sur le thread crappy design aurait dit
ça m'a bien amusé et j'en ai vu plein
d'autres outils qui sont sympas dans la
vraie vie sur terre est si vous croisez
des trucs comme ça qu'on a un design qui
a pas du tout tout témoin fait une
petite photo et d'août est le mois
penser à moi mettez moi bien je suis
très friande ça me fait trop rire c'est
trop marrant ça sont les erreurs bêtes
et gentille sans conséquence ça me fait
toujours rire qui a un côté mignon
autour de ça je trouve c'est rigolo je
vous dis à ta vie dans une prochaine
vidéo pour parler à moi je sais de quoi
je vais vous dire d'elle
[Musique]